Traduttore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Revisore: Federico MINELLE
[Applausi]
Il 15 marzo del 2019 è stata
una giornata particolare,
i giovani sono scesi
in tante piazze del Mondo
per esprimere un messaggio
di contrarietà
nei confronti dell'attuale
sistema energetico,
ancora troppo fondato
su fonti energetiche fossili.
Negli ultimi mesi le tematiche ambientali
sono notizia di tutti i giorni,
non c'è notiziario che quotidianamente
non parli di eventi meteorologici.
A volte, sulle prime pagine dei giornali
vengono riportati dei titoli
un po' provocatori e scettici
nei confronti dei cambiamenti climatici,
associando ondate di freddo
fuori stagione,
come quella che si è verificata
nelle scorse settimane
che ha portato neve e ghiaccio
o gelate tardive a quote collinari.
Ed è sicuramente un evento eccezionale
fuori stagione, ma non si può associare
un'ondata di freddo all'annullamento
degli effetti dei cambiamenti climatici.
Molto spesso ci si dimentica
della differenza che c'è
tra il meteo e il clima.
Gli eventi metereologici
sono episodi locali e limitati nel tempo,
mentre gli eventi climatici -
il clima valuta il tempo
su un più lungo spettro, su una regione,
su un'area, su una nazione.
Infatti si parla di riscaldamento
del pianeta.
In ogni caso, grazie
alle manifestazioni dei giovani,
il mese di marzo di quest'anno
può essere considerato
una linea di demarcazione,
una presa di coscienza sul fatto
che occorre intervenire, occorre porre
dei cambiamenti all'attuale sistema
di sviluppo e consumo di energia.
Il prossimo appuntamento
dello sciopero mondiale per il futuro
è fissato tra due giorni,
il 24 maggio 2019.
Questi eventi, la loro intensità
e frequenza, ci fanno toccare con mano
un problema enorme, una crisi ambientale
definita da molti ormai irreversibile.
Ovviamente questa irreversibilità
va vista nell'ordine di grandezza
della vita di un uomo.
Quello che si può e si deve fare
è intervenire per mitigarne gli effetti,
perché non abbiamo un'alternativa,
non abbiamo un secondo pianeta.
In realtà probabilmente la prima presa
di coscienza avvenne nel 1968,
quando un torinese, Aurelio Peccei,
decise di fondare il Club di Roma:
un'associazione no-profit che all'epoca
riunì scienziati, economisti
e personalità rilevanti
di tutti i 5 continenti.
La missione era quella di individuare
i principali problemi che l'umanità
si sarebbe trovata ad affrontare, cercando
di identificare soluzioni alternative
ai diversi scenari possibili.
Dopo 4 anni nel 1972, il Club di Roma
pubblicò un rapporto dal titolo
"I limiti dello Sviluppo",
dove metteva in evidenza le problematiche
alle quali si sarebbe andati incontro
nei prossimi decenni
se il modello di sviluppo
non fosse cambiato.
Da lì ad un anno, nell'ottobre del 1973,
avvenne un improvviso aumento
del prezzo del petrolio,
i prezzi del greggio
aumentarono di oltre 4 volte,
decretando quella che tutti ricordiamo
come la Crisi energetica del 1973.
Quella crisi stimolò la ricerca
di nuove fonti alternative al greggio.
I governi dei paesi industrializzati
occidentali iniziarono
a varare provvedimenti nell'ottica
della riduzione dei consumi energetici
e negli anni successivi l'efficienza
di utilizzo dell'energia
incominciò ad aumentare.
Ed allo stesso tempo continuò
ad aumentare la sensibilizzazione
sulle problematiche ambientali
e nel 1988 venne fondato l'IPCC.
Un gruppo intergovernativo sul cambiamento
climatico fondato da due organismi
delle Nazioni Unite:
l'organizzazione Meteorologica Mondiale
ed il programma delle Nazioni Unite
per l'Ambiente.
Lo scopo principale dell'IPCC
è quello di studiare
i cambiamenti climatici
ed il riscaldamento globale.
Il riscaldamento del pianeta
avviene a causa, principalmente
dell'aumento della concentrazione
di un gas considerato climalterante,
il principale gas ad effetto serra:,
l'anidride carbonica,
formula chimica CO2.
L'anidride carbonica non è un gas
pericoloso o dannoso per l'uomo, anzi,
permette la vita sulla terra, permette
delle condizioni vivibili sulla terra.
Il problema sta nel fatto che
quando questo gas,
la concentrazione di questo gas
aumenta fortemente,
è correlato un aumento della temperatura.
E a un aumento della temperatura avvengono
con maggiore intensità e potenza
gli eventi meteorologici.
Nel 2004, si è concluso un progetto
di ricerca europeo, chiamato
Progetto "EPICA", sia perché è stata
un'impresa epica, sia perché significa
European Project Ice Core Antarctica,
che ha permesso di ricostruire
la concentrazione di anidride carbonica
sulla Terra negli ultimi 800.000 anni.
Da poche settimane si parla del progetto
"Oltre EPICA" che permetterà
di ricostruire la concentrazione
di anidride carbonica
fino a 1 milione e mezzo di anni fa.
Nel progetto EPICA è stato perforato
uno spessore di ghiaccio del continente
dell'Antartide di 3.270 metri
ed è stata rilevata la concentrazione
di anidride carbonica nelle particelle
d'aria contenute nel ghiaccio stesso.
Il risultato è quello che vediamo
nel grafico, ovvero
che negli ultimi 800.000 anni
la concentrazione di anidride carbonica
non aveva mai superato il valore
di 300 ppm (parti per milione).
Oggi siamo sopra le 400-415 ppm
e questo valore cresce
ad un valore di quasi 2 ppm/anno.
Se consideriamo che l'Homo Sapiens
si è sviluppato circa 300.000 anni fa,
oggi stiamo vivendo una Terra
dalle condizioni chimiche
mai viste in precedenza e solamente
negli ultimi 150-200 anni
di rivoluzione industriale
abbiamo fatto un salto che ci ha spostato
dalle 300 alle oltre 400 ppm
di anidride carbonica in atmosfera.
I responsabili di questo incremento
siamo principalmente noi,
attraverso la combustione
dei combustibili fossili.
Pensiamo a cosa facciamo noi
tutti i giorni: viviamo in un'abitazione,
questa deve essere climatizzata,
andiamo a scuola, al lavoro,
ci spostiamo e consumiamo energia.
Per lavorare, studiare, mangiare
consumiamo energia,
solamente a stare seduti in questo
teatr, ostiamo consumando energia.
I nostri stili di vita influenzano
il consumo energetico,
vestirsi adeguatamente
in funzione delle stagioni.
Ѐ vero che non esistono più
le mezze stagioni, ma il 40% dell'energia
che viene consumata è consumata
all'interno degli edifici
e questa fetta è fortemente influenzata
dai nostri stili di vita.
Il fatto che ogni azione che svolgiamo
comporti un consumo energetico
è la realtà, occorre solamente
esserne coscienti,
al fine di intraprendere
le migliori soluzioni
che è possibile intraprendere.
Ma l'energia che utilizziamo
tutti i giorni,
la benzina al distributore,
il gas e l'elettricità a casa
come fanno ad arrivare li?
Cerchiamo di ripercorrere
in ordine il percorso:
innanzi tutto l'energia
deve essere prodotta,
per quanto riguarda
i combustibili fossili
deve essere estratta,
se pensiamo al petrolio,
che ne vengono estratti quasi
100 milioni di barili al giorno,
oppure al gas naturale,
questi due combustibili possono
essere estratti dai giacimenti
attraverso queste piattaforme,
come quelle in figura,
mentre per quanto riguarda il carbone,
le modalità di estrazione sono differenti,
ma gli effetti di una massiccia estrazione
dal sottosuolo possono essere questi:
il fenomeno della subsidenza:
se io tolgo il materiale dal sottosuolo
quello che c'è sopra sprofonda.
Quindi, dopo che le fonti primarie sono
state estratte, è necessario trasportarle
dai luoghi di produzione ai luoghi
di utilizzo attraverso delle tubazioni,
per esempio dei gasdotti, degli oleodotti.
E nell'attesa di essere distribuiti
agli utilizzatori finali che siamo noi,
è necessario accumularli.
Affinché un sistema energetico
sia affidabile,
ovvero che garantisca
un approvvigionamento energetico,
è necessario che si disponga
di riserve di energia,
sia per motivi ambientali,
perché potrebbe verificarsi
un inverno particolarmente freddo
che ci fa consumare più energia
di quella che abbiamo previsto
di consumare, oppure per motivi legati
ai fornitori perchè, se decidessero
di interrompere la fornitura,
ci metterebbero in difficoltà.
Fino ad adesso abbiamo parlato
di fonti fossili tradizionali,
che vengono prodotte a partire
dall'estrazione, ma l'elettricità?
Non esiste in natura, non è possibile
estrarla dal sottosuolo,
abbiamo però la possibilità di produrla
attraverso diverse fonti primarie:
quelle tradizionali o molte altre
(il sole, l'acqua, il vento, ecc..)
I consumi di energia elettrica crescono
costantemente perché è più facile produrre
l'energia elettrica da fonte rinnovabile
che il petrolio da fonte rinnovabile
e poi perchè l'energia elettrica
è la forma più nobile di energia
che esiste ed è facile trasformarla.
Se pensiamo bene, possiamo generare
del calore attraverso delle classiche
resistenze elettriche oppure
utilizzando delle macchine un po' più
efficienti, le pompe di calore,
possiamo produrre del freddo,
possiamo utilizzarla in motori elettrici
e muoverci i treni o gli autoveicoli.
L'elettricità però ha un grande problema,
non può essere accumulata con facilità,
come per il petrolio - lo mettiamo
in un serbatoio - oppure il gas naturale
- lo inietto nel sottosuolo - nei vecchi
giacimenti di gas naturale, ormai esausti,
l'elettricità deve essere
prodotta quando serve.
Questo grafico raffigura
la potenza elettrica
che in questo momento
stiamo consumando in Italia,
sono le undici meno un quarto,
il nostro gestore
della rete elettrica nazionale per oggi
aveva previsto un consumo
pari a 35 mila MW
e questo significa che in questo momento
vi sono centrali idroelettriche,
termoelettriche e di altre tipologie
che stanno producendo esattamente
quella potenza.
Ma ritornando al tema dell'accumulo,
se mi riscaldo con la legna, cosa faccio:
durante il periodo estivo faccio
una bella scorta affinchè ne abbia
a sufficienza per tutto l'inverno,
fare questo per l'energia elettrica
non è possibile.
O meglio non è possibile farlo
in modo semplice.
In questo momento tutti in tasca abbiamo
un accumulatore di energia elettrica,
il cellulare ne possiede uno, la batteria,
ma il nostro sistema elettrico nazionale,
quali accumuli possiede?
Attualmente la rete elettrica nazionale
possiede i bacini alpini,
sono il suo accumulatore.
Appunto, gli impianti idroelettrici
per pompaggio funzionano esattamente così:
possiedono un bacino di monte
ed uno di valle e trasferiscono
l'acqua dal bacino di monte
al bacino di valle a seconda
se la rete elettrica nazionale necessita
di immissione di elettricità in rete
oppure se ne possiede un surplus,
ne assorbono per trasferire l'acqua
dal bacino di valle al bacino di monte.
Aggiungere nuovi grandi bacini
può essere complicato,
quello che però forse può essere fatto
in modo più semplice
è estendere la metodologia
di generazione distribuita
che si è fortemente diffusa
con gli impianti fotovoltaici,
all'accumulo distribuito.
Pensate quando il numero
di auto elettriche aumenterà fortemente,
Ogni auto avrà una batteria
e quella batteria è un accumulatore
di energia elettrica.
Il nostro sistema energetico,
per poter aumentare la sua quota
di energia prodotta da fonte rinnovabile,
per aumentare la sua affidabilità
e di conseguenza la sua sicurezza,
deve necessariamente aumentare
la sua capacità di accumulare
l'energia prodotta da fonti rinnovabili
e possedere un adeguato
mix di generazione.
Il mix energetico è importantissimo,
perché il fatto di approvvigionare energia
da fonti differenti e, se pensiamo
in particolare alle fonti rinnovabili,
cerca di ridurre in modo naturale
il problema dell'aleatorietà della fonte.
Il problema più grosso da risolvere
è la discontinuità di produzione
Il sole c'è di giorno, ma noi
l'elettricità la vogliamo anche di notte
o quando è una giornata
nuvolosa o piovosa.
Pensando limitatamente
ai consumi elettrici
è necessario approvvigionarsi
da fonti differenti, per esempio l'eolico,
il fotovoltaico, quindi
la sorgente solare,
la sorgente terra: la geotermia,
l'acqua: l'idroelettrico.
Avere la possibilità di programmare
la produzione energetica è fondamentale.
Se non è possibile farlo accendendo
e spegnendo i sistemi di generazione
perché non sempre il vento
ed il sole ci sono, è necessario cercare
di accumulare l'energia
quando è possibile produrla,
per poterla consumare quando non c'è
la possibilità di produrla,
a scapito di una perdita
di energia stessa.
In ogni caso già oggi, il nostro
sistema elettrico possiede
una buona percentuale di energia
elettrica prodotta da fonti rinnovabili,
storicamente basata
su impianti idroelettrici,
ma che negli ultimi anni
ha avuto una forte spinta
grazie agli impianti
fotovoltaici ed eolici.
La percezione di molte persone,
forse un po' scettiche al cambiamento
è quella di sostenere
che i pannelli solari
oppure le auto elettriche
che possiedono una batteria,
siano tecnologie più inquinanti
dell'utilizzare sin dal principio
una risorsa non rinnovabile.
In realtà, prestigiosi studi di ricerca
hanno mostrato che
i pannelli solari fotovoltaici
nei primi anni di vita
generano tutta l'energia che è stata
necessaria alla loro fabbricazione.
Mentre per quanto riguarda
le auto elettriche, possiamo vedere
in questo esempio, a parità di veicolo,
solamente cambiando l'alimentazione,
facendola passare da gasolio
ad energia elettrica
acquistata dalla rete elettrica nazionale,
non ovviamente prodotta da un generatore
a combustione interna, come in figura,
bene, solamente cambiando l'alimentazione
è possibile ridurre di un terzo
le emissioni che sono considerate
emissioni climalteranti, ovvero
le emissioni di anidride carbonica
per chilometro percorso,
si riducono di un terzo.
Quindi, tralasciando le problematiche
relative all'autonomia dell'auto elettrica
che verranno risolte nel prossimo futuro,
spostare i consumi di energia
dalle fonti fossili alle fonti
rinnovabili e all'elettricità stessa
prodotta da fonti rinnovabili è possibile
e meno impattante sull'ambiente.
Quindi abbiamo visto che noi siamo
i principali responsabili e siamo quelli
che influenzano fortemente
i consumi energetici.
Ѐ necessario che sfruttiamo la possibilità
che abbiamo di cambiare.
Ognuno con le proprie possibilità,
anche economiche,
deve fare la propria parte.
Abbiamo visto che il sistema energetico
è complesso da gestire,
le fonti rinnovabili sono aleatorie,
alcune hanno una stagionalità
anche marcata, ma già oggi
vi sono delle tecnologie
che ci permettono di avere alti standard
di benessere, impattando
meno sull'ambiente.
Niels Bohr diceva che
fare le previsioni è difficile,
soprattutto sul futuro.
Quello che però sappiamo è che
se continuiamo attraverso
l'utilizzo massiccio di
combustibili fossili
il nostro unico pianeta
sarà sempre più malato
ed a pagarne le conseguenze saremo noi
e le generazioni future.
La fonte più rinnovabile
che abbiamo sorge tutti i giorni
gratuitamente ed è quella
che occorre utilizzare.
[Applausi]